Hó khoảng 2 giờ năm 5 phút hôm nay 208 năm nay như khu trăm 206.
Hó lửa bất nờ bự hát tại một hôm nay năm chiến khúc lộ mề bún,
thuốc hôm đần két, xa hoa phút đất lắc,
mua nhà này được gia đình xử dụng điệu cái hợp kinh dành bầu đi nước.
Ngày sau khi tiếp nhận tìm báo, lực lượng cạnh xa phòng trái chơi trái và cứu nạ
kêu hộ công an tình đặc lắc đã nhìn trong điều động về và phương tự hiện trường tổ chức chơi trái, cứu hồi.
Tên nhìn, sau bên trong cạnh nhà có nhiều và tự lửa dễ bắt được,
ngoại lửa bún phát sử dụng, kênh theo lự hỏi lớn,
gây nhiều khó khăn cho công tác tiếp cận,
sau khoảng 5 phút có mặt tại hiện chường,
lực lựa chức năng bục phải đập tự nhà bị cạnh để tiếp cận phía sau cạnh nhà,
đưa các nạn nhân dàng ngoài đi cấp dữ,
để khoảng 15 phút sau, đám trái khu bản được không triếp và giật tất hoàn toàn.
Mặc dù được đưa đến bệnh tự cấp dữ, như bún nạn nhân đã tự vọng,
1, 2,5 vội trường và 2 người con.
Xin chào Baisersing là con uống trong gia đình,
mấy mắn được cửa sống và hiện đang được đưa dự dị tại mình Việt.
Hẹn với nhân vụ trái đang được đưa chắc làm gió.